we're in love
oh sorry you don't like it oh my god my
depression is gone it's a very good gift
this look right here
oh hi
hi i'm lily reinhardt and today i'm with
buzzfeed answering your fan questions
and playing with puppies
they're over there
yay
[Music]
oh my god my depression is gone hello
hello
oh hi sweetie
oh
hello you little chewy chunk
wow
everything
is so okay in my life right now hello
you want to go waking here
[Music]
i thought it was very easy to actually
play two characters well because they're
the same girl it's the same girl just in
two different situations so that wasn't
really too difficult but um come here oh
i'm sorry what's your name oh you're
crying it's so cute
okay you can go over there i know can
they see here
come here no there wasn't a specific
story line that i preferred over the
other i think that that would be too
hard to pick i think they're both really
beautiful in their own way you are so
cute can i i'll let you come at your own
pace
[Music]
they all left me
i had a really wonderful time after set
one day with david we did karaoke of the
song shallow from a stars born together
we belted it at the top of our lungs
driving home from set one night and that
was really beautiful
you good
it was a really beautiful moment
honestly
it's reaffirmed how much i really love
being a part of projects from start to
finish come here my love what do you
want to play
yes it's just really reaffirmed that i
love being a part of everything all
aspects casting you know create
developing the script it's really just
such a fun process and so
um
they're fighting it's so rewarding at
the end of the day when the project
comes together and i know that i was
truly there from the start from the
finish and i had my hand in all aspects
of it so come here
come here
look at me
[Music]
that's a really hard question i think i
always would have wanted to be on game
of thrones that's just you know the most
iconic show of all time so
probably game of thrones
i'd play betty all day every day i
really am so happy with playing betty i
would not want to play anyone else what
do you
have you come in
[Music]
cami camila is the one who says and sees
the trends and and brings them to us and
most of the time i say i'm not doing
that because it's dancing and i hate
dancing she's gotten me to do a couple
but i definitely um
she definitely comes up with with a lot
of the ideas
[Music]
i met jenn
on set it was like right when we were
walking to set i didn't meet her ahead
of time so it was a little
intimidating and kind of scary but we
were doing a scene where she was like
putting her arms around me and
comforting me so it was a very
beautiful way to meet
jlo
[Music]
my friend taylor i don't have my phone
otherwise i would call her she'll always
answer facetime but my friends don't
facetime me out of the blue because they
know that i really
hate
phone calls and facetimes they give me
anxiety so out of respect for my anxiety
they don't facetime me unless i
request it
we're in love
oh sorry you don't like it
this look right here
i don't know when it was 2018 it was the
cfda's it was
rock collection uh a very pretty floral
number felt very me and all the dogs
have left me again come here
well for riverdale when our characters
graduated high school i took home my
diploma betty's diploma i have like
hoarding tendencies where i collect too
many things so i try not to take too
much home out of my own mental health
come here you
i don't consider myself a celebrity
unless i'm doing this right here right
now because who else gets to do this
[Music]
i think i would love to rewatch
everything everywhere all at once i saw
that in theaters when it came out a
month ago and i just cried and i laughed
i thought it was such an amazing movie
and i would love to relive that
experience come here
come here you
come here
[Music]
auditioned for many things lost a lot of
things i auditioned for glee i
auditioned for
tom hooper's les mis for gazette and had
to fly to new york and sing in person in
front of him which was the most
terrifying thing in the world yeah
obviously didn't get it probably a good
thing because i'm not a classically
trained singer and i would have
embarrassed myself
[Music]
recently a fan made me a portrait of
milo my dog
out of like
individually placed gems and it was so
just intricate and i just thought that
was the coolest gift anything milo
related is a very it's a very good gift
are you chewing my oh chewing my dolce
gabbana
no you're not
[Music]
a palo santo like the stick that you
burn for creative energy in my trailer i
just staged my whole house yesterday i
like to i like to do that to my space so
in my trailers i like to have a little
bit of a like a sage stick or something
i don't know
probably lady gaga when i went to the
met
uh whenever she was the host uh for the
theme camp i think it was 2018. she was
at the top of the steps greeting
everyone stop chewing the dolces i'm
sorry you're so cute but you cannot chew
the dolce you can sit right here though
saw her at the top of the stairs and
looked right into her eyes and was
genuinely couldn't find my my words i
was like uh
thank you for having me and walked away
and that was very embarrassing you're
just chilling out over here huh i feel
like my nervous system is reset my
cortisol levels are normal i have ample
serotonin and i'm ready for anything
after this puppy treatment thank you for
watching my interview all these puppies
are at wagmore pets and i hope you watch
look both ways on netflix august 17th
i'm just gonna collect this for a second
just create this uh discord this
okay
i love the way they smell they just
smell so good why are you humping your
siblings
[Music]
[Music]
you